i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back
to governing and therefore that's what
i'll do
because i work for you
new york governor andrew cuomo resigned
after facing mounting investigations and
various claims of sexual harassment
in my mind i've never crossed
the line with anyone
but i didn't realize
the extent to which the line has been
redrawn his resignation came a week
after a state report concluded that he
had sexually harassed multiple women
and just days after one of those women
filed a criminal complaint
alleging he groped her at the executive
mansion last year the investigation
found that
governor andrew cuomo sexually harassed
current
and former new york state employees by
engaging in
unwelcome and non-consensual touching
and making numerous offensive comments
of a suggestive
and sexual nature that created a hostile
work
environment for women though he
ultimately stepped down
cuomo criticized the investigation as
being political and denied
all allegations of harassment i want you
to know directly from me
that i never touched anyone
inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
cuomo's resignation
ends a 10-year run as governor cutting
his third term short
and marring his political career in
controversy a career that began
four decades ago by his father's side a
man who has
taught us all very much in this room and
it was taught me
everything i know governor mario cuomo
and first lady michael
comey cuomo began building his political
reputation as an ambitious and hard
charging democrat
while working for his father governor
mario cuomo in the 1980s
in 1990 he married carrie kennedy
joining two powerful political families
in a union some called cuomo cuomo went
on to serve as president clinton's
housing secretary in the 90s before
making his first run for governor in
2002
but that year he bowed out of the race
before the democratic primary
with polls showing he had little chance
of winning shortly after
he and kennedy announced their divorce
in 2006
cuomo was elected new york attorney
general and in 2010
he announced another bid for governor we
must use this moment
to reorganize the government reform its
ethics
and restructure its finances he cruised
a victory as he denounced albany as a
cesspool
touted his record as a prosecutor and
proposed a fiscally moderate agenda
this state has no future if it is going
to be the tax capital of the nation
we have to send that signal this session
by passing a property tax cap
during his tenure cuomo tacked to the
left legalizing gay marriage
raising the minimum wage if you work
full time
you should be paid a wage that provides
a decent living
implementing strict gun control laws
today new york is proud
once again to pass a first in the nation
the red flag bill and championing big
infrastructure projects
despite his liberal policies he
maintained support from business leaders
and won re-election twice
in 2014 and 2018. then
as the early stages of the coronavirus
erupted in new york
he burst into the spotlight like never
before holding daily press briefings
that gained nationwide attention
if a person comes in and needs a
ventilator and you don't have a
ventilator the person
dies frankly there has been a laxness
on social distancing especially over
this past weekend
that is just wholly unacceptable the
federal government
cannot wipe their hands of this and say
oh the states
are responsible for testing i don't need
the president of the united states to
read the constitution for me
maybe he should have read the
constitution before he said
he had the power to open the states
cuomo's briefings made headlines
and earned him a speaking spot at the
democratic national convention
only a strong body can fight off the
virus
and america's divisions weakened it
donald trump didn't create the initial
division
the division created trump
he only made it worse he also
capitalized on the crisis
signing a 5.1 million dollar contract
for a book about his handling of the
pandemic
the book launched in october amid a rise
in coronavirus cases
then in december a former advisor
accused the governor of sexual
harassment on twitter
others began to follow charlotte bennett
a former assistant in cuomo's office
sat down with cbs evening news offering
details of her story
what were you thinking as he's asking
you
these questions i thought he's trying to
sleep with me
the governor is trying to sleep with me
and
i'm deeply uncomfortable
and i have to get out of this room as
soon as possible i've heard charlotte
and her lawyer and i understand what
they are saying
but they read into comments that i made
and draw inferences that i never meant
they ascribe motives i never had
and simply put they heard things
that i just didn't say in march cuomo
welcomed an independent investigation
but when the probe that he called for
ultimately detailed a pattern of
harassment
he called the report biased and
continued to deny all
allegations of misconduct trial by
newspaper
or biased reviews are not the way to
find the facts in this matter
meanwhile cuomo also faced probes
involving his handling of deaths at new
york nursing homes during the pandemic
in march of last year when new york
became the epicenter of the coronavirus
crisis
his administration mandated that nursing
homes accept patients with covid19 in a
bid to free up hospital beds
the policy was widely criticized for
accelerating deaths in nursing homes and
the state reversed the mandate
two months later cuomo defended the
policy
but his administration withheld
information about the number of nursing
home related deaths
cuomo said it was because the data
became political
it's not about pointing fingers or blame
it's that this became a political
football
right but even members of his own party
criticized the move
they just need to own up to some of the
mistakes that were made
the various investigations took their
toll on the governor
and political pressure mounted following
the release of the state's findings of
harassment
are you now calling on him to resign yes
facing criticism from the highest levels
of his own party as well as growing
momentum for impeachment
cuomo stepped down thank you
for the honor of serving you
it has been the honor of my lifetime
god bless you though cuomo is leaving
the governor's mansion
his troubles may not be over several
local prosecutor's offices
said they planned to look into the
conduct described in the report